before I begin talking through the
question I want to tell you something I
want to show you something on this
diagram before I've even started to
solve the question I've done something
somewhat unusual on the diagram which
I've learned over time as a strategy to
help me see through questions like this
as I mentioned before part of the
problem is so many lines so he lines
everywhere okay so I want to try to
distinguish between some of them and
that's what I use colorful now you
notice there are only two lines I could
have done more but there are only two
lines on this diagram that are different
to the others okay they are AR and a s
okay the reason I've colored them
differently is because these two lines
share a property they're a particular
kind of line that none of the other
lines share now I've cheated a little
bit it's not really cheating but I've
cheated a little bit in that I haven't
just looked at the diagram I've actually
read the entire question you know how
you have reading time every time there's
lots of different ways to use reading
time but one of the ways to use it is to
read through the whole question and see
that can you notice for instance
something like say part 3 part 3
actually provides you extra information
that the original question or just the
setup for the question it doesn't tell
you it tells you stuff about a R and a s
do you notice that look at part 3 AR and
air so not just any lines they are
tangents right that's probably going to
be important I mean they say if they are
tangents prove yada yada yada so clearly
I'm gonna have to refer that so I want
to refer to these lines as different to
all the others okay so with that in mind
let's begin ah good question can I use
that for part one
I can't which is one of the reasons why
they put it into part three so part one
can be used for part two it can be used
for part three
but you can't reverse it I just want to
keep that in mind for the future because
I'm going to use the one diagram for all
three questions okay prove that PR is
parallel to Q s so where are P R and Q s
here and here okay
now P R and Q s you might notice are on
different are in different circles so
I'm going to need to rule
them in some way that's in common okay
so therefore the most obvious thing that
leads to my mind is to think well
there's only one feature that's actually
common between the circles it's a chord
but it's a bit sneaky because they
haven't drawn it in can you see what the
common chord is what's its name a B a B
do you see that a b is a chord in the
left circle and it's a caught in the
right circle okay so being that i've got
features from different circles i'm
gonna have to connect them in some way
this is a good construction to include
so with another color i'm gonna
construct a B there we go okay now
having done that I now want to think
what are the ways that I can improve
that lines are parallel there are
generally three properties that we use
that we talked about on parallel lines
if lines are parallel then we know this
we can use them in Reverse what are the
three kinds of features we look for on
parallel lines we look for Co interior
angles what else do we look for
alternate angles and what else do we
look for corresponding okay to have a
look I'm hopefully going to prove that
cue s is parallel to PR do you see any
corresponding angles here what would be
a corresponding angle if I had one like
corresponding angles they form like an F
right so if I had say this angle what
would it correspond to and the answer is
it would correspond to an angle out here
do you agree I need to extend this line
I don't have it yet I could but I don't
alternate angles where might an
alternate angle be on these two like for
example say this angle down here now
what angle would this be alternate to on
these two parallel lines if you have a
look at this guy here you need a Z don't
you that's what alternate angles look
like so you'd have to have a Z going
here and then it'd have to go that way
do you see that so there'd be an angle
on the outside and it would be alternate
to this angle now I don't have either of
those angles so I'm just gonna go
through the third one which are Co
interior what's the relationship between
Co interior angles there's supplementary
they add up to 180 degrees
now think in circles there are some
angles you know about that add up to 180
can you give me an example in in cyclic
quadrilateral opposite angles like say
oh I don't know these guys here right
you see their opposite angles in this
cyclic quad over here or these two here
they are going to be supplementary so
let's give this thing a name let's call
this guy feeder over here the angler
that's supplementary to our P a row
Prince Alfred what's it's supplementary
to what's the name of the angle that's
opposite yeah a br or RBA yeah they're
both fine Reserve Bank Australia ah
there's lots of great acronyms in here
so I'm going to label that accordingly
this guy over here is 180 degrees minus
theta I will point out you don't have to
call it theta of course in your proof
but it just makes it a bit easier to
talk about so I've got this guy over
here
it's 180 minus theta okay now if that is
Theta and these lines really are
parallel then what should this guy be
equal to these are the co interior
angles that I was talking about this
should've been 180 degrees minus theta
so I've got a 180 degrees minus theta
here how would these guys related this
guy is the opposite interior angle to
this exterior angle does that make sense
so if I say the exterior angle of cyclic
quad-a be sq I have no idea what that's
an acronym for is equal to the opposite
interior angle then BAM I've got the 180
minus theta that I was after is that
okay so my final line would be PR is
parallel to Q s because coming to your
angles are supplementary
it's that okay so I'm not gonna labor
the writing with that because I think of
that that's those steps are clear
opposite angles of a cyclic quad
exterior angle of a cyclic quad and
you're there okay part two part two says
mmm-hmm if ap equals BX ap equals BX
those guys here's ap he is the
X okay prove that a B which I've we've
constructed just now is equal to X P
which I haven't constructed yet okay
let's put these guys on now remember I
don't know that these are equal yet so
I'm not gonna put the lines on them but
I am gonna use color to help me identify
how these features are related sorry
don't mind me I'm just calling okay so
what did we just say X X P is for that
guy around here there it is and what was
the sign I'm supposed to compare it to a
B which is the one we put in black I'm
just gonna put a red line over the top
okay
so how can i connect these two together
well I want you to look at them
do you notice they they overlap and
they're both in this circle do you see
both of the those courts are in this
circle over here so I'm just going to
concentrate on this circle for a little
bit okay can you see there are clearly
some angles that are relate these two
sides to each other
for instance a P be a P be this angle
here if I call it something like say
alpha do you notice over in this circle
that angle is standing at the
circumference and it's on an arc what
arc is it on what arc is angle PA be
standing on a X so that arc over here
the angle that's there is an angle
standing on this but actually it's gonna
be this guys or not you see that ax
standing this is the angle standing on a
picture the legs okay I'm a person and
they're standing on that arc in fact the
angle I've marked is alpha I think it's
standing on arc pay RB this guy here
this long this big arc over here and
that's the angle that's formed you see
that okay so I want you to come back to
this big arc that's not the only angle
that's standing on this arc have a look
is there another angle you can see pxb
that angles also standing on that
arc and angles on standing on the same
arc are equal okay that's good that's a
good indicator if I've got these two
angles be equal hmm I've also been told
that these two sides are equal
I've got equal angles I've got equal
sides what kind of triangles can you see
that would pull all that information
together
I think our congruent triangles right
we've got lots of similar triangles in
in circles we've got lots of Conroe
triangles the the clue that tells me
it's congruent is that I've actually got
equal legs okay I need something else
though all I've got is a pair of sides
and apparent angles that aren't even in
the triangles that I need see see these
red lines our alpha is not in that
triangle so I need something else what
could I use deccan what do you say ax is
common aha so if ax is common I'm just
gonna put a wiggle on it okay I've got
that guy I've got this side here two
sides two sides I need an included angle
don't I I need an included angle but
look carefully the included angle here
isn't just alpha its alpha and a little
bit what's the included angle in the
other triangle it's gonna be this guy
right do you see the triangles I'm
looking at let me name them because
we're starting to get a bit more
information right so the triangles on
looking at our a P X a P X and triangle
what's the other one a X be very good
okay so remember how I said Oh
alpha and a little bit alpha and a
little bit so I'm expecting that those
little bits are the same but how can I
show that what information would I you
oh really I can't almost there so let me
show you let me show you I'm gonna call
this guy betta in here
betta okay do you notice it's standing
on or it's subtended by this court over
here do you agree with that see that can
you see it coming up into that okay
that's better
and this is the other little bit which
I'm expecting is also better it's
standing on another core what Court is
this guy subtended by a ap which but
they're equal they are equal right and
cause for attending this conference by
equal chords are also equal okay so I've
got side-angle-side
there's your congruence proof and these
two red lengths they correspond to each
other in those congruent triangles okay